I also need to mention this as we
continue along I think I may have to
return to my home state of Virginia
based on this report anyway out of
Virginia let's watch this
introducing a new bill centered around
parents and how they handle their
child's sexual orientation and gender
identity 7 news reporter Nick menach
explains why this is controversial
right now parents rights in lgbtq
protections are a big focus in Virginia
thousands of students in Virginia have
walked out of class protesting Governor
Glenn Young's newly proposed model
policies on the treatment of transgender
students at school
and Governor young can argues schools
shouldn't keep parents in the dark about
their child's sexual orientation and
gender identity these
these progressives in Fairfax County
actually believe that they should lock
parents out of their children's lives
they think that parents have no right to
know what your child is discussing with
their teacher or their counselor a
democratic Virginia delegate Elizabeth
Guzman is a social worker and she's
planning on reintroducing a bill in
Richmond that she says would help
protect lgbtq children from their
parents and Guardians who may not be
affirming of their child's sexual
orientation and gender identity this is
how we're gonna pushed back her bill
would expand the state's definition of
child abuse and neglect to include
parents who do not affirm their child's
gender identity or sexual orientation
there's an investigation also in place
that is not only you know from a social
worker but there is also a police
investigation before we make the
decision that there is going to be a CPS
charge what could the penalties be if
you know the investigation concludes and
it's concluded that a parent is not
affirming of their lgbtq child what
could the consequences be well we first
have to have an investigation you know
it could be a felony it could be a
misdemeanor but we know that CPS charge
could harm you know your employment
could harm your education and Alexandria
Nick minox 7 News
and delegate Guzman Carl 7 news that she
is home well you have to realize of
course is that this is in so this is in
Virginia where as we heard of the at the
beginning there obviously uh Glenn
Younkin is the governor so that means
that this bill is not going to be signed
into the law into law right now in
Virginia
but this is what they want to do
um and this is what they will do
especially in blue states where they can
get away with it
make it a it is child abuse
to not affirm
so-called affirm your gender confused
child you know in 2020 there were over a
thousand significant online data
breaches in the US which left almost 156
million people's records exposed that
includes sensitive information related
to children now uh you wouldn't let your
kids walk home from school without
telling them not to talk to strangers or
get into any windowless Vans or even
Vans with Windows actually but you let
them go online every day without a VPN
that doesn't make a lot of sense to
protect your family's privacy when they
go online you've got to use expressvpn
internet service providers know every
single website you visit isps can sell
this information to ad companies and
Tech Giants who can then use your data
to Target you
do you really want all these advertisers
knowing who's in your household well
your kids like to watch How to Target
them with whatever they're looking to
sell no you probably don't that's why
expressvpn protects your privacy without
showing your connection no matter how
many users are in your household unlike
other vpns you won't even realize you
have it on it's so easy to use just
download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and you're
protected nobody in your family is too
old or too young to figure out how to
use it secure your family's online
activity by visiting expressvpn.com Matt
walshow today use my link and you can
get an extra three months free
expressvpn.com Matt walshow
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show they're
already doing this in Canada
this was uh this is It's A couple of
years ago they declared that it's and
their their anti-conversion therapy yeah
I think it was Bill C4 in Canada
which uh which forbids conversion
therapy but what is conversion therapy
according to them
it is conversion therapy if you do not
affirm your child's confusion
so if you're if you have a son who is a
boy and says he's a girl
and you do not immediately accept him as
a girl then you are committing
conversion therapy
by trying to convince him that he is
what he in fact is which is a boy
so if you in other words if you do not
facilitate his attempted conversion
into another sex which is impossible
then you are guilty of a conversion
therapy
and that's child abuse you could lose
your kid
and parents in Canada have lost their
kids because of that
now the left wants to do the same thing
here in the United States
I saw someone on Twitter I don't
remember who but they uh you know
referred to this as kind of it's a we
know on the left they had their no fault
divorce policies
and for married couples
and so now what they're working on
basically is a no-fault divorce of
children from parents
they're looking for every way that they
can to sever that relationship sever
that Bond
and in the schools they they do it they
sever the bonds psychologically they
sever it emotionally
they turn parent the child against the
parent
but now they're looking for ways to do
it legally
just tear the kids away from the parents
and into the arms of the state
where the state can make of them
whatever they want
that's what they're looking to do and
that'll do it for us today uh thanks for
watching have a great weekend Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]